let's let's start with thinking about
this I want to lead a few things about
this this book the genealogy of morals
and Nietzsche and this might makes right
theory to try to draw a few things
together before we look at the nuts and
bolts of it so when you hear in
Nietzsche in today's culture he is
usually associated with this notion that
you know the strong pose their their
values their will on the weak and if the
weak don't like it then they can rise up
and show themselves to be strong
otherwise they're disgusting weak
cowardly they deserve what they're
getting only the strong actually
deserves to be valued pay attention to
that sort of thing and that is very
similar to this might makes right
through that through some a kiss was
expressing and you see people saying
stuff like this throughout all of
history I imagine you could probably
think of some other people in the course
of time have said things like that right
the strong they get what they get and
that's their right because they're the
strong the weak don't want to stand up
and defend themselves
screw the weak that's the might makes
right theory in a nutshell can you think
of any you know fictional characters
that that exemplify that that sort of
thing we have a lot of these in movies
don't we they actually say things like
that some of them some of the bad guys
and movies just do their things try to
justify what they're doing but if you're
if you're expressing the mind makes
right philosophy you're actually sort of
explaining a little bit of what you're
doing and usually in movies these are
the villains aren't they it might mix
right mentality people so the piece
okay
well that's interesting I have guys that
never had anyone bring up with a little
mermaid in this respect that's its aft
it works I was thinking more like you
know some space over here yes so in
adventure movie or something like that
but yeah that works whatever some other
groups where you got a fairly medium
kind of villain people actually say
things like better if I rule because I
actually have the guts to do what needs
to get done
I stand for force I stand for power
anything come to mind there you guys
watch a lot of movies better watches a
lot of movies
Jaffar okay yeah this is just a far just
about you know getting his hands up
things just really where does he want
power to he actually he wants power yeah
Darth Vader yeah you know Darth Vader is
an interesting look because he has like
that moral conversion right he's kind of
conflicted character definitely his boss
would be an example of that and how does
this boss get into things he sees a lot
of disorder he says you ask somebody
strong who's got to come in here take
charge but then he gets corrupted right
yeah so they need to get the idea to get
the general idea
now Nietzsche is not presenting it that
well I mean she actually thinks this is
a good thing and so in presenting it I'm
going to actually try to sort of take
the side of each as much as possible so
you can sort of try it on imaginatively
and see whether you think this would
would work work better than through
Simic astir stomach this probably didn't
convince you that well Nietzsche might
be a little bit more convincing he
starts out talking about several
different kinds of morality and this
this book by the way is divided up into
three essays and each essay treats a
different set of issues I've cut a lot
of it out because there's a lot of
digressions and a lot of extra material
we're not actually going to talk too
much today about the priest who's an
important figure in this but I want to
keep it as sort of just a to perspective
view and Nietzsche would say when it
comes to morality there is no such thing
as morality per se there are just
morality and you pick one or you pick
the other or you make your own but if
you make your own you're probably
getting action
to be doing one or the other and he
thinks that historically the original
valuation original morality took place
between the values of good and not evil
but what's the other contrary to too
good be rough and he wants to make a
distinction between bad and evil he
thinks that the fundamental
understanding of good changes depending
on whether you're opposing it to to bad
or to evil and so here's the way that he
sketches out it playing itself out in
the beginning in the beginning you have
in every society you have some people
who are stronger than others they become
the nobility because they're strong
because they're able to appropriate from
other people they're the ones who are
powerful and they impose their wills on
other people so that that's a
distinction of power right there how do
we get to morality how do we get the
good and bad well these are the people
who actually define themselves as good
and why do they do that because they can
because nobody else keeps them from
doing that if anybody wanted to keep
them from defining themselves as good
they could rise up and defeat them or
something like that but they don't and
they also impose on to the common people
the we the people who are less healthy
the people who are there view cowardly
less given to you know certain
themselves imposing themselves imposing
their own wills they give them the
valuation of bad and each has a lot of
like Greek terms in there and we don't
actually worry about those too much I
actually cut out a lot of etymological
material or he talks about
is also played out in Latin you know
ancient you know Celtic languages and
stuff like that we don't to worry about
that the basic point is that you see
this over and over again in primitive
societies this is the records that we
have about somebody setting themselves
up as the powerful for claiming
themselves is the good and imposing upon
other people that they are the bad and
the other than the bad people suck it up
and they they go along with it if they
didn't want to Nietzsche would say well
they would rise up and they would
actually become you know rivals to these
people and that's sometimes where you
see happening if you look at ancient
history I'm going and you know way way
back before Greece and Rome you look at
ancient Sumeria but uh Mesopotamia you
actually see people coming in from the
outside being born in quite low
circumstances and rising to become the
king of the city like Sardo did you know
a story about being born it you know
born and then being put in a basket
floating down the river and getting
found by somebody that we here with
Moses which is an interesting story
turns out also that the story for saga
pretty humble beginnings and he's able
to sort of rise why because he chooses
to because he exerts himself because he
makes other people into the tools of his
will so you know this isn't necessarily
a nobility where you're born into it and
then you stick with it as a matter of
fact if you're born into this nobility
and you don't prove yourself you might
fall from it into the ranks of the
common you know we might be seeing us as
a
coward right and in in trumpian ancient
societies that really stressed warlike
virtuous being a cowboy is like being
nobody was like being lower than so he
calls us the pathos of distance pathos
actually means feeling it's a Greek word
means feeling or emotion there's this
feeling this sense of distance and the
good are able to value themselves and
this has nothing to do like he says at
the beginning this has nothing to do
with notions of like egoistic versus on
egoistic or altruistic this only has to
do with notions of getting to decide for
yourself what counts as good and then
imposing that valuation onto to other
people so he he says you know when do we
start worrying but ego is they can
untwist it when something else happens
what he calls the slaver molten around
that he says the collapse of
aristocratic value judgments is when
this entire contrast between egoistic
selfish right a none egoistic unselfish
disinterested good for other people
pressed itself strongly into human
awareness says that's the instinct of
the herd which through this country's
finally gets its word and eventually
though the masses they impose a nucleant
evaluation which
and they become the new master but they
don't they don't become a master in the
same way that these kind of individuals
do this sort of rise up and exert
themselves and impose themselves I want
is beloved well on this a little bit
more he says a few other things about
this he says these people named
themselves after a typical
characteristic and if you actually read
ancient Greek literature ancient Latin
literature I'm going to sort of take it
out Nietzsche's word that if you read
ancient Iranian literature's I can't
read this stuff or quality to read
ancient German literature to deviate or
things like that you see this taking
place they named themselves the truthful
they call themselves the escalopes
he says a man who is who possesses
reality who really exists who is true
yeah so this this is sort of turning
political superiority the capacity to
rule other people into what it calls
spiritual superiority superiority in
terms of higher values and I'm going to
skip over this discussion about the
priests just do not a few other ones he
says this Knightly aristocratic
judgments of value has their basic
assumption of powerful physicality a
blooming rich even overflowing health
together with those things required to
maintain these qualities what did he
need in order to maintain that in like
the ancient world before we had you know
Planet Fitness and things like that down
the road war adventure hunting dancing
war games and in general everything
which involves strong free happy action
so you know the nobility are able to
engage in these things that are
typically human that are things that
some people actually do on vacation
these days right people go off on
hunting trips we have to like make time
for that dolly adventure but I can you
know go out
you don't draw it on the Saturday night
I suppose war games everything that
involves strong free heavy action so so
these are people who don't have a waffle
lot on their minds are they are these
people who are punching a time clock
worrying about getting to work on time
or about you know getting an assignment
done for for the next class and ethics
or anything like that I don't think so
these are people who are you know really
enjoying life and they're doing that
because they're they're tough they're
strong they're powerful because they
actually are willing to you know do
whatever it takes to be powerful and
people that they've imposed this on
maybe some of them you know could rise
and you know fit in there but if they do
more power to them that's fine but for
the most part these are the people who
are punching clocks who are farming
fields who are preoccupied with these
sorts of cares who when they get into a
fight are the ones who back down or I'm
going to sort of throw themselves in
there's one other thing I want to get up
to before I talk about the slave herbal
says the wealth board felt that they
were the happy ones they didn't
construct their happiness by looking at
their their their enemies or talking
themselves into being happy they
associated happiness with action with
activity with doing something but they
actually being out there in the world
and making things happen
now generally what that means is making
things happen to other people so that's
where this you know imposition part it's
not just like working out themselves if
these guys were getting into
competitions they would have to be the
ones winning the competitions and they
would feel like you know they're on top
and Park as all these other people are
lower than them right but they also take
joy just into competing so I think you
know there's there's a certain part of
us that can
late - this isn't there even if you know
or not these people necessarily there's
a part of us that can relate to this
there's a part of us that actually want
to see people like this kind of likes to
watch that identifies with them perhaps
your dreams about being like them now
let's look at the other valuation he
calls this the the slave revolt in
morality and you know he also talked
about the herd you get the idea that
from Nietzsche being a common person is
not a good thing right
being somebody who fits in not a good
thing and he was a pretty good example
that he wasn't a person who fit in very
well he also was not the you know
Superman that he describes here he
actually was fairly unhealthy suffered
migraines Switzerland spent a lot of
time laying in bed to be able to do the
writing that he did but you know that's
not all of us measure up to our own
ideas so he talks about this this slaver
fault
he says slave revolt and morality begins
when what he calls Rosanna mom we're
going to look at that war in a moment
becomes creative and gives birth to
values the resins a month of those
beings were prevented from a genuine
reaction these people down here do you
think they like the strong imposing
stuff on them at all this is really nice
can't imagine a better life how do you
like it what people force you down and
make you do things what does that feel
like let's sort of put that on the table
okay intimidating what else what else do
you feel let's add some pop quiz right
now you know how do you feel panic
perhaps right how else oh yeah yeah be
ticked off right tell is this this isn't
the way the rule of the game is supposed
to be played
I'm already doing stuff that I didn't
want to do like get up and you know go
to an 8 o'clock class and you know did
the reading and you know look through
this stuff an oiler and I'm up to date
with the homework and what the hell
right that's that's the reaction a lot
of people would have it's an
understandable reaction each you know
fix that that's that's perfectly normal
what happens if you try to resist those
who actually are powerful what's your
experience how many of you like at one
time or another gotten yourself into a
fight with ministration or boss or or
something like that very few of you I'm
surprised I'm willing to bet that maybe
your parents if your parents are
domineering what's it like what happens
typically yeah they're no they're not
really lay down your lunch bag yeah they
don't say oh I see the I see the rat the
the reasonableness of your your
complaint I can't believe I imposed this
thing upon you that was so unfair let me
fix that for you let up are not usually
they don't stay powerful lawyers they do
they say what do they did it crack down
right I'm going to make you regret
having crossed me isn't that more often
what happens I remember a teacher when I
was in Middle School he was wrong
had to do something in like civics class
and I was camera smart you know smart
aleck in class and so I pointed this out
and he was a teacher and I was a student
right and so this is very you know back
then is very very hierarchical and I
insisted on the fact that I was actually
right we gave me detention and you know
my mom came and you know she was choose
I figured she'd take my side because
after all I was right and this is it's
wrong to impose detention on somebody if
they don't deserve it isn't it the well
she actually took his side she said look
he's the teacher think it's the do
whatever he wants you better shut up
next time so now think about all these
sorts of experience I think you've
probably had lots of experiences like
this you know your boss comes down on
you for something you can't say what you
like to do your boss right what happens
that feelings I did it go away just you
know ten deep breaths I think you know
serenity now or something like that that
really work I got what's your experience
on that what do we do typically if it
will get our angry feelings out yeah but
the friends
actually very can't say that the boss
right so you say something dear friends
of him that person such a jerk
can't believe they do that you know this
isn't the first time that they've been
like that
and then after a while your friends and
family probably get sick of it and say
well you know stand up to him or
something along those lines but until
then you do that and that's for
Nietzsche that's what the common people
tend to do they don't actually like rise
up and oppose force openly with their
own force they kind of talk of talk
behind people's backs and tear them down
and try to make themselves feel okay
about that when really the reality is
they're stuck in this body position so
the slave revolt in reality takes place
with what he calls a transvaluation of
values things being turned topsy-turvy
so the noble good person the noble
powerful I'm acting to interview that he
hasn't views mean selfish person gets
put on the bottom and they are they're
not good and they're not bad without
oddly what are they what's the other
value that's possible well set is that
neutral in this case evil right they get
defined as evil by the common herd big
person who then it's to define
themselves by contrast as good and the
the difference here it is it should be
you know market to you the null person
is imposed is decided that I'm good
and they impose this other category on
the other people the other people don't
like it they can actually you know make
their own categories or they can rise up
or they can fight whatever the common
hurt people they don't start by defining
themselves as good and then defining the
noble people as as evil they first
defined the noble people it's evil it's
a sort of reaction against them and then
only after doing that do they define
themselves as good good mean not evil
there's no real positive content to it
so you know what's an example of an evil
thing that evil people do okay I was
think of movie villains Thursday yeah
before right what makes Darth Vader evil
other than wearing black that's how we
know he's a bad guy Rexy wears a black
Talman stuff like that he's got that
medicine voice right think about the
very first Star Wars movie how could you
tell that this guy was a bad guy in like
the first five minutes yeah
jokes you guys yeah I think they call
that force choking
for Chuck's again it doesn't movie after
movie right there's actually an
interesting piece I read recently I
think is that cracked row saying Darth
Vader's terrible leader because his
solution to you know people failing
force-choked that doesn't motivate
people to do their doesn't but he does
fit the type right so it forced choking
people losing control of your temper
that's evil right so what's good not
losing controlling your temper forgiving
people when they do the wrong thing
taking them aside and giving them
another chance counseling them all that
sort of stuff but in ninjas view there's
real no positive content there you're
just not doing with
people the evil people and you get to
make yourself feel good by contrasting
yourself done equal evil man I would be
like that boss [ __ ] somebody gave me
power when I would treat all my
employees really well I would care about
a thing and I wouldn't you know mess
around with their schedules and order
others experience
take out my frustrations on them that
give raises and all that sort of stuff
people say that sort of stuff because
they're imagining themselves actually
having power and being like in the
position of the powerful and then just
not being evil it's kind of funny
because you know there's a major company
that has as one of its like ethics
statements don't be evil they don't know
which one that is
ok Google how far does a cadet you as a
guide to life don't be evil how far do
you think will that carry you through
all your moral dilemmas that you're
likely to face without helped you out I
help a lot of you face moral dilemmas
you know particularly appropriate ones
before would that have helped you out
somebody just coming along don't be evil
let me tell you which does it no they
they do form some ideals that the other
thing that he talks about in terms is
process all and if you want a sort of
thumbnail sketch of what results in all
this that's what happens when things
happen to you that you don't like and
you're powerless to do anything about it
that just kind of gnaws at you and stays
in you and sours within you and becomes
part of who you are changes your
a character he talks about this well
ready to pass it to retie synopsis
he says the all mobile mobile morality
arose out of the triumphant affirmation
of one's own self slave morality from
the start says no to what is outside
other to a knock itself and this no is a
creative act this transformation of the
glance which confers value this is
inherent and resulting so that tells us
what's going on what what is result he
says being unable to take being a unable
to actually take revenge on one's
enemies that's part of it he talks about
results about having poisonous eyes it's
only really much later that it gives you
a good characterization of it so I'll
read this section from the third essay
it says uh every suffering person
instinctively seeks a cause for the song
so I think when you're a kid right you
stub your toe is it your fault that you
stubbed your toe when you're a little
kid who's falling moms it could be your
mom's yeah I just don't get it solo
Thank You Yeti like you kick it again it
turns out to be really dumb because you
know you stuck your toe out at first
I see like a tractor when it doesn't
work when I was a kid how's that done
yeah
man things made out of metal yeah where
we seek around for other people you know
kids will actually one kid look of it
like punch another kid and then the
teacher will come by and say what's
wrong with you
why did you hit you know little Susie
over there and what did what does a kid
can say she made me do it it's her fault
this is very common among kids every
suffering person instinctively conceives
a clause for his or her suffering or
more precisely an agent or more
precisely a guilty agent sensitive to
suffer somebody who we can take revenge
on on one pretext or another we going to
load our feelings either in fact or he
says in effigy
what's an effigy you guys know that word
we have an effigy of something somebody
we burning somebody in effigy was that
me yeah yeah so like if you want to burn
you know well we don't um cool Sam
doesn't exist right this somebody wants
to burn Uncle Sam show you know they
don't like America they make an Uncle
Sam out of paper mache converting that's
a burning in effigy is so I don't you do
that with your boss we can actually
model of your boss and I'll turn off the
fire and that would make you feel better
right
they seek sudden living person they can
unload their feelings either in factor
in effigy
why because unloading our feelings is
one way in which we seek relief when
we're suffering he says it's an
anesthetic it's our narcotic against
torment he says this is the true
physiological cause it was on savant
revenge things related to that longing
for some anesthetic against pain through
ones of motion and you talked a little
bit more about this
you know people lame think people blame
other people and things not only for the
immediately but also for where they are
in society don't they I mean in this
crappy position this dead-end job this
you know unfortunate one down place
because somebody screwed me if their
fault if I could just hurt them take
something away from them then things
would be okay with me that's that's
resultant that's what nature thinks is
going on with this valuation getting
away from good and bad to good and evil
he thinks that's what's going on at the
ordinary person he thinks that's also
what's going out of democracy with
socialism with you know everybody gets a
gold star making everything equal he
thinks that that's eroding our sense of
values replacing them with a false
reactive sense of values they won't
actually make us happy something else
goes on with this as well and this gets
to do with like the freedom of the will
this is in the first essay he says to
demand from strength that does not
express itself the strike so we're
talking about the tough people that does
not consist of a will to overpower a
will the thrill' able to rule a thirst
for enemy's opposition and triumph is
just as unreasonable to demand from
weakness that it expresses itself the
strength so Nietzsche has got this idea
that you know you look at people and
there are some people that just by the
way they are they can't like seek out
comfort don't they do you know any
people like that are any of you people
like that maybe and I was still handled
it a lot happier down but not so much
but then there's other people who does
kind of like a boycott
verse risk-averse yeah can you do an
awful lot with changing somebody if
they're one way or the other if you tell
them hey [ __ ] up get yourself in there
think about when it comes to romantic
matters in dating and stuff like that
how many of you have had a shy friend
like somebody and they just couldn't go
talk to them and you know like you yet
you were trying to get your shy friend
to go and actually talk to this guy or
talk to this girl and maybe ask them out
or something like that
how'd that work it worked well you push
them come on and get over there take a
chance
some people's going to take chances
right other people haven't have no
problem whatsoever they have this
confidence that doesn't seem to be based
in anything you know I was always kind
of like in the middle more probably more
on the shy and at first I had some
friends man these guys were ugly stupid
you know really didn't have a lot going
for them but they could let just go up
and talk to girls you know and why
because because they did they just went
and did it
right and it works that way with with
jobs and it works that way with with a
lot of other things too there are some
people just don't want to do it right
they he says it's strength that
expresses itself the strength
same thing with weakness you candidly
expect from somebody who's weak that
they're not going to be weak in here so
he says a quantum of force is just a
quantum of force will drive action it's
nothing but that's very driving willing
itself so the powerful people just are
powerful that's how you know they're
powerful they show themselves that way
the weak people there's a weak they just
show themselves that way it's sort of
like putting sports teams out on the
playing field right you want to know who
the
winter actually is play the game and
people can say afterwards well you know
they would have done this a little bit
differently and now this a little a
little bit differently but they didn't
write King laid out the way it did and
you know like for instance you know it
this is a somewhat disappointing season
again for me as a Packers fan because
I've watched our defense which is better
than last year
just like shrivel and you know disappear
against some people's offenses right and
I could have said well you know we're
really good we just made a few mistakes
here they're no you can see it on the TV
you know it's not only these people
could like punch through our lines and
then squirt touchdowns we were weak
after that we did a little work I mean
silly even for me to identify that the
team isn't that from an ancient
perspective I'm weaker than Abel there I
couldn't stop some you know running back
plowing into me let alone some you know
offensive lineman but I saw I'm
imagining myself that's because I'm
really a weak person I'm not football
but even the ones out there playing
football some triumph some didn't you
only never who's trying to his week by
actually looking at who comes out on top
so he says what people do over here is
they look at the strong and they say the
strong could have done otherwise he says
popular morality separates strength from
the manifestations of strength as if
behind the strong person were in in
different substrate you know some sort
of like indifferent neutral somebody
brought forward neutral before some sort
of neutral position which is free to
express strength or not but there is no
such thing each a sense there is no
being behind the doing acting and
becoming the doer is merely made up and
added into the action so now if you have
this point of view you say you know the
strong people they don't actually have
to push their a gem
their power and their wills on other
people that's a choice on their part
they could do otherwise then you can
start to criticize them can't you you
can start to call them evil as he says
it's no wonder that the repressed
secretly smoldering feelings of rage and
hate use this belief of themselves and
basically even maintain a faith and
nothing more fervently and the idea that
the strong are free to be weak so that's
what make a strong evil from this point
of view the strong are free to be weak
and you know I put this word mean down
here let's put another word up here by
be nice why can't it just being nice
that's the refrain of the common herd of
the week why can't they just be a nice
person why do they have to be so mean
all I mean I know that you know if we're
going to run a business
somebody's got to like it have rules
crack the whip a little bit yes loudly
I'm not near anybody well that doesn't
make any sense does it
couldn't they maybe just have a
recording of cracking the whip but not
that actually crack a whip it kind of
puts people walk when you when you bring
that out that's the way that the nice
the weak would look at the strong they
could do otherwise and if they can do
otherwise then they're responsible for
being so mean for hurting other people
then he says you know now if that's the
case then the nice amount of the week
could actually look at themselves and
say I don't choose to hurt people I did
just as much as the strong people I
could be mean like them but I choose not
to be so I'm good they could be good if
they wanted to they just have to quit
being so tough but trying to control
patrina I think people do things their
way quit trying to be different and
higher than other people so me says I'm
actually a scripture that's fairly
quickly the the week you actually
appropriate virtues to themselves they
see themselves as the only people who
are honest good you know just carrying
all the in these sorts of things they
attribute these values themselves but
really they're just reacting to trying
to be different than these other people
and they use these as kind of like a
scapegoat for why things aren't are good
it was just you know if these people
would just knock it off
quit being so mean but being in a war
like quit you know taking more than
record share they would like be heaven
on earth
and everybody would get along so
Nietzsche says you got to choose between
one or the other of these and in the
society we live in there's kind of a
mixie things so I'm actually going to
skip a little bit ahead and talk about
what happens at the end of each of the
three chapters and then we'll come back
to this this idea of where we currently
are so he says these two opposing values
is in a section one have been fighting a
battle on earth for a thousand years
what are the two opposing values good in
bad
versus good and evil they've been
fighting a battle on earth for thousands
of years and the second value good
versus evil has got the upper hand for a
very long time and he says that the
battle has been drawn to greater heights
and greater depth and has become more
and more spiritual so that nowadays
there is no decisive mark no more
decisive mark of higher nature somebody
who's actually you know got real
potential a more spiritual nature than
that it's split in that sense so if you
actually waver between the two
these you might in fact be this person
but in the culture that we currently
live in where this is what's getting
pushed all the time then you're and
you're going to internalize some of this
struggle inside of you which valuation
should I go with yeah in order for you
from Nietzsche's perspective might makes
right thing in order for you to do the
right thing you want to actually strip
this away so you know think back to your
your elementary school high school
middle school how many of you have one
thing or another guy kind of upset with
the fact that it seemed like there were
some areas where everybody got a gold
star everybody was you know everybody
won everybody got a medal none of you
came from an environment like that my
kid can t play dodge ball doesn't even
know if dodgeball is because dodgeball
in walls you know throwing balls at
people and that might hurt people and
hurting people's mean right know what
I'm going to get hurt up playground
that's this sort of viewpoint none of
you came from an environment like that
you all came from an environment like
this succeed or perish
yeah I'm good I feel a power generation
more like this yeah interesting my
sister's like six years younger so but I
can see it's starting to feeling more
yeah I saw it back in my time the shift
that was taking place I think it really
depends on where you go to school there
are some schools there's actually a
great book that came out about ten years
ago is called hard america's soft
america and it made this contrast
between areas where look if you don't
perform that's it you know and then
areas where everybody gets a gold star
that was hard american soft america said
you know a lot of schools are turning
into soft america which is not too good
because then once you get the workplace
what's the workplace like harder yeah
unless you go to government work like
that get into a union sometimes so if
you let's say you did get into you were
in that sort of situation and you didn't
like the kind of everybody get some old
stuff you might still also be able to
see some point to it don't you feel bad
sometimes for the people who don't win
who suffer you don't go back to them at
all sometimes everybody I think
everybody feels a little bit the
question is what do you do with that
what makes your calls pity do you allow
that to sort of spew you over into this
point of view it's our job and really
just take care of the nice people the
weak people ones who don't come out on
top
Nietzsche says that this struggle
figures
this struggle actually runs throughout
every society every institution every
family we're going to find this passage
every every sort of situation that you
could possibly imagine
yeah here we go the desire is sick
people to present some form or other
superiority for the nice for the weak
for the sick to be in charge their
instinct for secret paths leading to its
here any over the healthy for the
healthy Noble where can we not find it
is very will to power the weakest people
take a look into the background of every
family of the corporation every
community everywhere you see the
struggle of the sick against the healthy
quiet struggle for the most part of the
little poison powder with need length
with the seasonal expressions of
long-suffering but now and then again
that sick man's parasite tactic loud
gestures whose favorite will those noble
indignation getting upset with other
people for being too mean for being too
competitive for imposing their values
and you know for not getting along with
other people he's saying this this runs
through all of us this runs through
every institution so we all either need
to decide you know are we going this way
are we going this way that and for
Nietzsche if you're going to go this way
he says great you fit in with me and if
you're going this way says got nothing
more to say to you you're your object
showed yourself as being one of the weak
the other thing that he says about this
is this kind of interest in this mostly
in section three
he talks about our culture itself as
being sick being pervaded with sickness
and that this is you know a
manifestation of that and whose job is
it to take
the sec this is this brings up an
interesting sort of paradox imagine them
that a plague broke out here in the
united states are you just here because
let's say the wall in our city right
don't want to don't want to get out who
should take care of the sick people what
do you think
here's a doctor's but sure but in terms
of like sick or healthy you should be
taken care of
should the help you take care of the
second yeah people wise yeah it well you
might want someone else to get sick has
done this is a misery loves company
right but if you're if you're helped
that you should stay the hell away from
sick people this isn't a common cold you
know that you're going to get over this
is a sickness that goes to the depth of
one's very soul according to nature so
if you're actually healthy you should
actually resist everybody's pressure on
you that's being brought for you to be
sick like them and from you using of the
strength that you have to serve the sick
let the sick take care of the sick and
they can't take care of themselves
that's that's too bad for them they
don't really deserve to live according
to meet you they don't deserve anything
the only people as you deserve anything
from each are the ones who can actually
take it who actually create them to
bring contributions who stand out so you
know what do we see here you know to
sort of recap this is that might makes
right philosophy is done this is a much
darker much more radical version of it
than through some abysus this one
actually can make sense out of why most
people don't see it this way I don't
myself endorses but I've been presenting
this as if you know I was immediate but
just so you can sort of get get your
head around and see what merit what
virtue it might have if you're attracted
to this sort of thing in our society
you're probably not going to be a
warrior out on the lines although either
do you guys think that will be a few
good men Jack Nicholson's character he's
one of these Tom Cruise's character is
one of these in that that famous speech
you can't handle the truth you want the
truth you can't hand
the truth the truth is that you need
some people out on the front lines we
actually do the tough things that would
be the sort of mentality where else
would we find this in our society though
that's pretty rare you know we don't
have too many people actually on the
functional lines where else would we
find this this sort of view where it's
not really just about protecting the
weak it's about sort of imposing
structure opposing or coilette proposing
values who also be doing this
yeah
well so that the government is really
serving the weak you know think about it
most of our the highest expenditures
that we have written out or what we call
entitlements what our entitlements about
paying people you know for things that
will keep them from hurting Medicare
keep them from suffering ninja would
probably say screw Social Security and
Medicare you know let these people in
fender themselves so the government that
we currently have both parties by the
way we need you with not attributes for
Republicans or Democrats who wouldn't
would you look at
yeah what's up yeah if you could if you
could actually become a dictator that'd
be great if you trouble with dictators
that are only being one of eight if you
have a dictator
now you notice though a lot of dictators
get into power by by sort of coddling a
weak Hugo Chavez is a good example
exercises to ramp the power does so on a
benefit to the to the you know backing
of the weaker forces in this society
what about in business business can be
can control right you know any types to
my fitness would say hey either succeed
or you fail if they I don't anything to
do with you I'm here to mix with winners
like they took you know the Forbes or
take Barron's or any sort of business
magazine let's say you cut out all the
philanthropy parts you know where people
are actually benefiting other people you
just have like those robber barons I'd
be a good example or in entertainment
who would be the people who really
matter the most the hardest forget to
call their own shots right all right
actors who become directors being an
actor is one of it being a director now
that's power
Danya producer that's even more power
you can do whatever you want that can
you think of any other areas or you know
like it says this the supplies and every
family the supplies and every
corporation would there be any people
say a family or a relationship if you
were in each yet probably dominate the
other person or people make them do
things your way they don't like it let
them rise up then they actually can be
respected it's a camp in there week and
you don't want to actually like listen
over here saying you know we should all
be in the log you should be nice I think
you can imagine a lot of cases in which
this this will fly the funny thing and
I'll close with this the funny thing is
in my life I have met quite a few people
at Park Olympics and philosophical
circles who have called themselves in
each ian's and a lot of them don't
strike me as actually living up to this
you know they seem to be more filled
with with rose on to month and ranker
them you know in shows character over
here who's supposed to be not very free
very open liberated all that sort of
stuff I think these days probably if you
were really an HTM you wouldn't brag
about it you wouldn't tell people hey
I'm Andy Chia you know carrying around a
book of Nietzsche all the time show
everybody just you know without complete
in a cutthroat mean person you are when
all you're really doing is carrying on
the book you're not actually doing
anything for Nietzsche the only way you
could fit this type would be actually
doing something and I don't think too
many people who you know meet this type
these days are spending too much time
reading Nietzsche as a matter of fact to
do things just Nietzsche's way wouldn't
that be for somebody else have kind of
control over you there's a little bit a
little bit of paradox there so that's
where we'll leave a lot